Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to The Joy of Creation.
Now, this is the story mode demo. Which
means that there's a full game of this
coming out soon, but the previous
incarnations of this game were kind of
just technical demos to show you what
these horrifying animatromos can do.
But this one takes place in a lovely living
room.
"What could go wrong?" I say so confidently
to myself
as I wait to be torn apart and
stuffed inside a d-oh...
Am I- Oh. No?
Hello? Oh! I can- Oh!
Woah!
Woa-OHEYY!
Why am I going towards
that door?
Hello.
*unintelligible*
Ok, how do I get- Oh there we go. Good God!
Ah.
Ok, this isn't what I thought it was
gonna be. It's kinda a little bit different.
Ok? Alright so- WHA I DIDN'T DO THAT!
*static from TV*
I DIDN'T DO THAT!
AH! WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT?!
Ok, excuse my bitcheous nature there...
*flrbr*
I'm not ready
for this. I haven-
The fuck was that?
Woah! Fucking goddamn it.
Hey! How's
it going?
Okay. All right, now I'm starting to get
it.
Ok, so I remember- I remember the first
joy of creeee-
♫ -ation game that I ever did. It was a lot
like this. ♫
Oh.
Hi!
I see you down there!
I see you! I got you! Ok? What do I do
about that? Is that Freddy?
Or is that Bonnie?
Who is that?
Who are you?
Oh god.
eugh
Okay. Well
that's not good.
Ok, so Chica is on the monitor. Ok, so
there's a Freddy...
*static* AHH- DIDN'T DO THAT STOP DOIN' THAT!
Who's turning out the lights?
Ok, so there's a Freddy poster on this
side I'm assuming that-
I'm assuming that that's Freddy.
Chica's over there, Freddy's over
there...
Oh, that's a Bonnie poster on the right, so...
Right, I did... Was there an option to - there
must've been-
Ah, there we go!
HI! Who's there?! Is that someone?!
There's someone there!
I spy- AH! WHAT THE FUCK?!
What the fu-u-u-uck? Was that a door opening? I think it was.
Ah fuck fucking shit!-
Hey!
Is that Foxy?
That better not be foxy back there.
I'll give him a what for of what's been on my mind!
*static*
AH! FUCKING COCK!
I shouldn't answer this door, should I?
Hello?
What the- HO-HO-HOLY FUCKING SHIT!
HI! WHAT ARE YOU-
*LOUD SCREAMS FROM EVERYONE*
*thump*
AAAH!
aaahheeuu...
I survived 2:50...
Fucking cock!
What does that mean?
"GAME OVER" "YES/NO''
I don't know what that means. What do you want from me?
Oh my god! I don't know. Yes? Yes? No?
Did I do wrong? I don't know.
I'm assuming that was like a
continue thing. Just written a little weirdly.
Alright, so now that I got my bearings,
maybe I can last longer than a
little under three minutes!
Ok so..
*hugh*
Alright, so Freddie is over there
B-Bonnie's over there Foxy is coming at
you from behind and Chica is over there.
So!
What we gotta do is a whole lot of I don't
fucking know.
And then-heheh
Then we gotta hopefully survive
long enough to be able to tell our families
what the hell happened to us. Hello!
You're gonna be-
Oh, hi. I see you down there.
Well you're far away aren't ya? That's okay.
I'd rather you-  *static*
*static*
God what is that?! Shut da fuck up man!
Ok, is it bad that the lights stay off? What I'm- I'm kind of tempting-
*door creaks*
Fucking Foxy!
You're not welcome here! You have no friends!.. Here!
You have lots of friends outside of here,
and they're all trying to get here,
but you're just a little early to the party.
Why don't you go home? Go home, Foxy.
Ok, so Bonnie...or atleast withered b- oh...
Hi! How are you doing?
I shouldn't stare at you, should I? But I just can't help it.
You're so goddamn fr-*Static*
UFF, I was f- I was right there! Okay.
You know what? I'm gonna tempt fate here.
*static*
Cuz wanna see if Chica comes crawling
out this TV like the goddamn ring.
I will be fucking pissed but I'm just gonna waste this attempt on unwanted death
*static*, *door creaks*
STAHP.
*static*
Nothin' over there? Nothin' over there?
Okay! AH! FFF-FFECKING
What was that?! What was that?!
...
What was that?!
I hear something! WOAH I HEAR SOMETHING!
Ah, it's in my ears!
*static*
Ohh... I'm beginning to think that this is a bad idea.
I'm going to think that I maybe shouldn't have done this.
Oh, why am I committing to this?
AAH!
I could turn on the light at any goddamn moment!
Oh fuck.
I'm dead. I'm dead.
Unless I'm not which is cool too...
FUCKING GOD!
OH MY SPINE!
Owie!
I survived two seconds shorter
than the last time.
Goddamn it. Alright, let's try that again.
this time with a lot less stupid. I don't even know if that was Chica that got me.
I closed my eyes like the little bitch-baby that I am.
Should I keep an eye m-
like, the question raised in my mind,
God damn it! Hang on! Holy shit!
T- hold on
hold-
hold- hold-
hold- hold- hold your-
Fucking god dammit!
So anyway I don't know if I finished my
thought before because I was screaming
like an idiot,
Why? Is that the thing that is that?
But this is a lot like the very first
Joy of Creation game that I played if
this is this is obviously not free roam
its kind of blending five nights at
freddy's 4 with some other thing but
this is what the first one was about
it was about spinning around in a room and
trying to make sure that no one murders you
but I'm still trying to wonder- wait, is that vent s- ooh.
Oh no, the vent's nothing okay i'm still trying to wonder
why am I in this room in the first place
How did I get here? Why am I
watching this on the TV? Because in five
nights at Freddy's at least
*door creaks*
I was just looking at you!
In Five Nights at Freddy's, you know,
*acute static noise*
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
You gotta warn me first! Fuck off with
yeh! Oh, it's quiet.
Oh it's quiet.
Anyway...  *static* Ah shit!  Before I question the
logic of this game any further...
Oh fuck off with you! The thunder is really
picking up its wumpage.
Eugh!
Five Nights at Freddy's you're a security guard in a-in a -in a security post.
If this is supposed to be story mode,
I don't know what the story is! Oh... Woah, wait. What did that do?
Why did that do that?
Okay...
I don't get it!
I don't get it. So, if you click forward
you kind of *door creak* h- Hi, hi! hey hey whoa okay...
or is that how you do it?
To do the quick turnaround on that one? Ah, that might be it.
Ok, so let's check over on Good Old Bon-Bon.
How ya doin' Bonzo?
You better not be-
Who's behind you?
Who the fuck is behind you?
Who's behind you?!
Who the fuck is THAT?
Wh- I - that's not explained! That's one more!
Who the fuck is behind him?
Who the f- Who the fuck was behind there were more eyes!
♪Oooooooh!♪
Get buh fuck back! Get buhfuck back! Get buhfucking buhfuck!
So who was behind him? *static* God dammit stop that.
Who... Who's behind him?
Or is is that just a reflection? Is that a very inconvenient reflection?
It could be, but it also could
be something else.  it's kind of I don't
want to make any bold claims here but it kind of seems like it might be...
It's very narrow that's one thing to note about it
is very narrow....eyes which kinda reminds
me of the puppet.
*door creak* I-I haven't seen the puppet at all in this type of game so it's either the puppet or a very...
Oh god. What's happening?
Where'd he go?
Ah! He's looking at me!
No, he's not looking at me he would have red ey-
*LOUD SCREAM*
WHY?!
Who did that?!
Who?! Who did that?!
I got over three minutes.
Jesus! This is hard!
Either there's something
that I'm missing which is totally
understandable considering that i've
never played this game before, but holy
shit I don't know what's going on I'm
gonna give it one more try
If you go towards the door when they're right outside of it
You is going to die!
He's going to grab your-
AH
FUCK!
Maybe it's just, like, total time
spent...
No! It's still there! It's still there!
What is that? It's not just a reflection
off of Bonnie. That's something!
That- That is a hundred percent something...
And, if I'm not mistaken, if you look down towards the
bottom like that piece of paper flashing
I see the shadow of something spindly like a leg.
And I may just be-
I may just be fooling myself there, but I calls it like I sees it.
That's something. Excuse my spit.
Ok. He's back.
Ooh! I heard that! I heard that!
Flippity-floppity.
Get da fwobady!
Woah! Okay.
Can I do anything with the thermostat? If
I make-
*LOUD ROAR*
WHY?!
What killed me?!
And why?!
Oh, look! Proof! It's gone. The eyes are
gone.
So there was something over there.
There was definitely something over there.
There was a hundred percent something over there.
I'll go back right now you guys
can see the eyes are literally- They're there now!
They weren't there before! They're there now.
That is something! What is that?
Seriously, what is that in the darkness?
There's been a rogue element here that's
been killing me but I don't know what
the fuck that is.
if I, like, go back and forth
between this is gonna press it
more? *door creak*
Oh shit. Well that ain't good. I'm gonna die.
*static*
Ah fucking cock!
*Loud roar* *thump*
What did that?! What did that?!
What is that?!
I don't know what that is!
One, one, one.
Aw jeez, okay. No. I hope that didn't close the goddamn game.
Ok there's a lot of mysteries in here
and I don't know how to solve them.
I'm at-  I'm at a loss. I have no
idea.
So, I'm gonna leave this up to you guys I'll put a link in the description below.
You guys play this for yourself.
Let me know what you think, and let me know if you find any other secrets in
this because it seems like there's a lot
of them. So, I'm gonna give my heart a
little bit of a rest here because my god!
It would not stop killing me.
But either way let me know what you thought of it down the comments below,
and thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye-bye!
Oh god.
NO